- We're in the middle of our first ever
Designed By Drew segment,
where I get to surprise
this very special family
of five essential workers with
a backyard transformation.
Check this out, they have no
idea what's about to happen.
I'm so excited, I love surprises!
The Copenings have no
idea this is happening.
The team was able to pull
this off in five hours.
Behind their backs, we
plotted and schemed.
And yay, I hope they like it so much.
I really wanna thank our friends at Weber.
They were kind enough to gift
the Weber Genesis to the Copening family.
And Ooni, they're a pizza oven
company, they kindly donated
this beautiful outdoor pizza
oven and this entire stand.
I'd like to give a special
shout out to Tyson as well,
because they've gifted the
Copenings groceries for the year.
SYNLawn donated the grass.
Then we also were able to
work with Pottery Barn.
And they were able to give
us these amazing table
and chairs and this gorgeous couch.
And we talked about should we do something
really colorful for the Copenings?
And my design aesthetic is
usually very color-forward,
But lately, because of
the state of the world,
it's so chaotic out there
that I keep wanting to create
spaces that are very
calm and very neutral,
and don't maximize more than three colors.
I'm really happy with the end result.
And I hope they like it too.
- Okay, I think they're
here, I'll be right back.
- Oh my god!
- Oh!
(family cheers)
I wanna be adopted into your family.
- Oh you got it, Drew,
you come right in front of Mike, Mike.
- And Shakia, you're like
the queen entertainer.
- Yes.
- You bring the games
and the karaoke.
So I brought some like games for you.
I brought some grilling
books for you, Papa Mike.
I know you're the grill master.
- Yes.
- I am so happy
to be in your backyard.
I'm your boo Drew, and I'm trespassing.
(family laughs)
Come sit down, relax in your new patio,
your new beautiful backyard?
Okay.
- This is beautiful.
- Why us?
Like, I'm excited that
it's us, but I'm like, us?
- Can I just ask one thing?
Can we just keep this yard?
This yard is beautiful.
- We love this yard!
- This is all yours.
- Wow.
Nothing's going anywhere.
- Oh my god, I love it, I love it.
- I can't decide who does
a more important job.
And the world is in a different space,
where it has a new name, essential.
There are new capes, there's
respect, there's heroes.
And for that, I'm so grateful
for what you guys do.
And so we wanted to show you
our appreciation by hooking ya up.
(family cheers)
How was it working in assisted
living during coronavirus?
Did it change you as a person
to be a part of so much of passing on?
- Yes, it changed me, definitely.
Even though me and my family
were close, we got closer,
because you really got to
understand who you can depend on.
- To just like still be able
to come home and have our unit
be safe, be healthy and be in a place
where we can still like
celebrate and enjoy each other.
- You work at the MTA?
- Yes.
- And Papa Mike, you work at the MTA?
- [Drew] And you are at the post office.
- Yes, 24 years.
- Mail is so important.
- Yes it is.
- What you do is so important.
- Thank you.
- I'm like one of your biggest fans.
- Thank you, I'm glad to know.
Did y'all hear that, bus operators?
- Teachers too.
- That's right!
And you're a teacher!
- Yes.
- My favorite thing, obviously
there's so much work to do,
but the fact that 2020 has
doctors and nurses and teachers
and bus drivers and the
post office and everything,
may we never, ever, ever not be
in the lane we are in right now.
So thank you.
- And if I had to, Drew,
I would do it all again.
- Thank you, Drew.
- Yes.
Thank you.
- I would do it all again.
- I Love you so much it hurts!
- We love you.
- Love you.
- I cannot thank you guys enough
for having me in your home.
That's your family home
that you grew up in.
- Yeah.
- And you're keeping it going
by raising your own kids here.
Well, I wish I could hug you guys.
- I wish I could squeeze you, Drew.
- I want a group hug,
soon, when it's safe.
- That was amazing.
- That was incredible.
- That was, oh my god.
- I did not expect that at all.
- I didn't expect that at all.
- No.
This is the best day of the year.
- [All] Thank you Drew.
- We love you you so much, we love you!
- What a wonderful family.
We thank you for all that you do.
And to you watching, do you
have a space that needs help,
or know someone who
deserves a special surprise?
Please go to our website
and tell me all about it.
(upbeat music)